(typing)
- Guys, bad news.
Due to budget cuts, I'm gonna
have to fire one of you.
The good news is whoever
is laid off will receive
six months pay in their pension.
So before I do
assessment interviews,
is there anyone who would
like to voluntarily step down?
Seriously?
You hate it here that much?
Do I suck that bad?
(farting)
- Oh, okay, guys, come on,
we all know Richie sucks,
but let's not be
children about this.
- No, no, that was me.
♪ Oh, we got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect
♪ 'Cause baby we got it made
So, Anita, you and everybody
else wants to get canned?
Why do you think you--
- Every day I've worked here
I've thought about killing you.
(Richie nervously laughs)
- Okay.
- Stab, shot,
burned, titty-fucked.
- Doesn't Jesus say something
about not murdering people?
- Jesus had to take
out some niggas.
This motherfucker called him
a bitch for wearing a robe
and he said, I ain't
no bitch, motherfucker.
Then he Selena'd his ass.
- Both offensive and
historically inaccurate.
- Then him and Harriet
Tubman teamed up to fight
the white people with machetes.
- Where do you go to church?
- Elmer, you're the
best employee I have,
why would I fire you?
- My comedy career
is about to take off.
- You've done three
open mics and only do
Jack Nicholson impressions.
- Show me the money.
- He's not in that movie.
- Do I make you horny, baby?
- Not in that one either.
- We need to get some
lawn and order in this
special victims unit.
- Do you have any idea
who Jack Nicholson is?
- Richie, if you don't fire me
I'll sue you for discrimination.
- So you want me to fire
you for being black?
- [Lyle] Yes.
- I can't do that.
- How about for being gay?
- You're not gay.
- Oh yeah?
How about now?
- Hey, hey!
That felt good.
Can you do that again
and tell me I'm pretty?
Christine, I'm gonna fire you
so we can finally be together.
- Is donating my vagina
to science an option?
♪ I never knew
what love could be
You're right, this
wasn't sad enough.
- It's from Scrubs.
From a scene where they
stop being hilarious
and start being real.
I've got Sisqo's Thong
Song if you want something
more upbeat.
- Regarding this
firing situation,
you've got to act
like an adult here.
Listen, I know everybody's
terrible at their job,
but you gotta dig deep
and you gotta figure out
who's the most terrible.
- I'll do it for you, Christine.
Can I put this stereo down now?
- You're arms are
hurting already?
It's been 20 seconds.
- I signed up for the
online Zumba course.
Zumba, move over Pilates,
there's a new girl in town.
You know what Zumba is, right?
- Yeah, I was just wondering
how my life got to this point.
- Alright guys, I've
made my decision.
- What is it?
- I've fired that
Mexican janitor.
(groaning)
- He's got three kids!
- He never says hi!
- He doesn't speak English.
- Oh Jesus,
Christine, hola works,
I'm not a monster.
(sighs)
Lyle, could you
softly touch me again?
- Hell no.
- Oh yeah, that's the good spot.
♪ We got it made
♪ Yeah, nothing's
gonna get us down
♪ Everything's perfect